the federal government is launching
several proposals to tackle the student
loan debt crisis and a recent one is
aimed at lowering the amount of those
repayments Nevada State College also
trying different things to lessen the
debt burden for students Joshua peguero
visited the school as its President says
she's focused on providing affordable
education
does the Impala is only giving her
second state of the college address
continue to be mindful she took the helm
as president of Nevada State College in
2021 and her intentions are to close the
gap between rich and poor especially
when it comes to access to college we
also do other things to help support
students to get to the end to the degree
they include a scholarship opportunities
Nevada state recently received 1.3
million dollars in federal grants this
is to help first generation college
students obtain doctoral degrees 80
percent of Nevada state college students
and alumni end up staying in the area
and there's a focus in the school on
educating the next generation of
teachers it will cover all tuition and
fees after financial aid for one year
for students pursuing a degree in
teacher education it's part of an idea
of Pollard says to incentivize students
for us tightly coupling ourselves with
CCSD and being a co-creator of solutions
rather than a Critic has been a powerful
opportunity for us Nevada state boasts a
highway attention rate among first
generation college students zany Smith
is one of those students my father was
diagnosed with a chronic illness and
over time he was no longer able to work
there have been times throughout my life
where my siblings and I had to step up
to help at home Pollard says she'll be
working with legislators in Carson City
this upcoming session to increase
funding at Nevada State College Joshua
peguero eight news now